the publisher of Prince Harry's new
Memoir says it is selling at a
record-setting pace and record is the
word listen to this numbers readers
brought more than
1.4 million copies of spare on the first
date was published last week that's huge
the book is still making headlines of
Reddit this weekend it's worth a read
even for Harry's brief comment that his
family made a fortune from the slave
trade the fact that fact rather is
generating a whole lot of talk about a
very disturbing part of the monarchy's
very long history Holly Williams has
that part of the story
the British Monarchy is known for many
things Pomp pageantry and family Discord
but less well-known is its connection to
slavery I mean it goes all the way back
to Elizabeth the First the British
Monarchy has been heavily involved in
financing
enslavement Voyages of traffickers but
also beneficiaries of actually the labor
of enslaved Africans Esther Stanford
cosei is a lawyer and reparations expert
the governor of the royal African
company was James II otherwise known as
the Duke of York they also found ways of
branding African people with the
inscription d-y for Duke of York
enslaved Africans were branded with the
initials of a member of the royal that's
correct that's correct members of the
British royal family have expressed
their sadness about links to slavery but
have never apologized
that the appalling atrocity of slavery
forever stains our history
I want to express my profound sorrow the
reason why he doesn't go further is that
he is aware of what it will mean to
actually apologize in terms of the legal
obligation to make reparation he's
worried that it could cost him and the
monarchy money not only money but status
he will be exposing actually the
criminality of this institution
historians say it's impossible to
calculate exactly how much wealth the
monarchy generated from trafficking in
human beings but when William and Kate
visited Jamaica last year they were met
by protests demanding not just an
apology but reparations and the trip was
criticized as a damaging throwback to
colonialism including this meeting with
local children through a wire fence
one Royal who has addressed his family's
connection to slavery more explicitly is
Prince Harry in his book spare he
acknowledges that the monarchy rests
upon wealth generated by exploited
workers and thuggery annexation and
enslaved people in terms of Prince Harry
going this far it's really really
important we can see the establishment
reaction including the establishment
media who are seeking to belittle him
demonize him because he is daring to
speak Universal truths and actually be
in touch with the conscience of humanity
we reached out to the Palace this
morning for comment they had nothing to
say on the topic of reparations but
pointed out that Prince William has
referred to slavery as quote abhorrent
saying it should never have happened
Nate
Paula Williams in London thank you
Harry is exposed a whole lot of Truth in
addition to his own life he's talking
about some very uncomfortable truths
that many people think need to be
acknowledged there's been a mixed
response yes his truths yeah yes I mean
it should have never happened but it did
happen and history as a way of showing
up in people's wallets so the question
really is should those wallets be bumped
up a little right about they don't want
to talk about that yep